when people think of the Frieza Arc they
think of the Super Saiyan transformation
they think of the climactic battle
between good versus evil and the chaotic
search for the namekian dragon balls but
man for me that only begins to scratch
the surface and what's more as a kid it
marked the very first time I was so
moved by a particular story that I
simply had to figure out why it made me
feel that way 20 years later I'm happy
to say that these are my findings last
week we covered the Saiyan Invasion on
Earth but this week we're plunging
ourselves headfirst into the deep dark
reaches of The Starry Night Sky
unwittingly on route to a certain Lion's
Den the likes of which none of us could
have been ready for not Gohan not
Krillin not Vegeta not even Son Goku so
sit back and get comfortable everyone
because this is how Akira Toriyama
changed the Dragon Ball world forever
and establish one of the most iconic
moments in all anime history this I am
of course talking about is the
terrifying the captivating and the
endlessly entertaining culmination to
one of the central plot threads
introduced in Dragon Ball Z this my
friends is the iconic Frieza Saga
[Music]
foreign
I explored the prevailing message of the
Ark being that the differences we are
criticized and demonized for if we try
hard enough become the strengths that
Define and ultimately save us the
mission statement of this Arc expressed
loud and clear that all of what Goku
represented was a virtue against the
evil which Vegeta represented and in the
end Goku's good triumphed over Vegeta's
evil at least that was until a certain
amount of poison slipped through the
cracks of Goku's apparent virtuous
facade when he quite selfishly requested
Krillin to spare Vegeta's life simply
because it would have been a waste to
erase such rare fighting potential that
someday he wished to fight him again
with that somewhat contrasting footnote
coloring what was otherwise a rather
uplifting and gleeful ending to say the
least we once again returned to
Melancholy as we prepare to embark on
the most ambitious Journey this story
has ever attempted for the very first
time leaving the safe and comfortable
confines of the Earth's surface and
venturing forth onto the stars above to
explore answers to a problem established
in that very last Arc how can they get
more Dragon Balls to rescue their
friends that gave up their lives for the
Earth against the Saiyans once again put
into the test those very differences the
prior Arc celebrated the Frieza Arc
takes to its natural extreme asking the
question what happens when you encounter
a foe the likes of which your friends
can help you best who threatens your
very family someone that forces you into
a corner to fight not with what you've
learned but instead forces you to lash
out with Instinct necessitating you to
contend with what you are instead of Who
You Are
the Frieza Saga of this story is a
fascinating deconstruction of the
Bedrock philosophy established in the
prior testing it and pushing it past its
limits to reveal something honestly
exceptional but to get there we have to
start at the beginning
act one okay so right off the bat one
important aspect of Dragon Ball Z
structure is abundantly clear something
that made this story incredibly
difficult to put down for me when
reading and something I feel isn't taken
advantage of nearly enough in the modern
material and that is
your arcs to
take Dory beats for what's to come what
do I mean
touched on last week the likes of Yamcha
chaotsu tin shinhon and Piccolo all bit
the Dos thanks to the Saiyans and due to
Piccolo's death the earthlings not only
now can't wish back the likes of chaotsu
but they can't wish back anyone ever
again it seems however in passing in the
middle of a conversation Napa and Vegeta
shared Toriyama dangled a potential
solution right before our eyes naturally
we aren't too worried about that while
we're covering that material because
everyone is dying and we're waiting for
Goku to get back to Earth to make the
save but thanks to that small piece of
exposition that small amount of time set
aside to explain that very small piece
of information we now have a natural
cause and effect between the Last Arc
and this new one due to the events and
information disclosed we now have a
motivation and goal to strive for in
other words because the Saiyan Saga
happened therefore the Frieza Saga must
happen and Dragon Ball super it really
struggled with this with each Arc
feeling as though they were independent
islands of story largely disconnected
from one another when the universe 6
tournament ended it ended it had a
conclusion and then suddenly we get a
cold open into the Future Trunks
material that wasn't informed by the
prior events in the slightest now this
does happen once in Dragon Ball Z but it
happens for a specific reason to Mark
the ending of a particular era sort of
but I'm getting a little ahead of myself
with that no spoilers for boo you gotta
wait for that one but anyways yes the
Fallout following the Saiyan Saga is a
large component to what ultimately
defines the setup for this one every
fighter involved is hospitalized or in
critical health and funnily enough they
all have their eyes set on the same goal
to gather the namekian dragon balls and
while Vegeta's path to that goal seems
rather straightforward that isn't the
case for the earthlings who are tied
down by their current Technologies or at
least that's what we're led to believe
due to that beneficial cause and effect
I spoke of early earlier the legwork of
the prior Arc makes the journey Dynamic
possible for the earthlings in a very
believable way for if Piccolo is a
namekian so too must Kami be and if Kami
is namekian he must have come to Earth
somehow and so enter Mr Popo with the
single fastest form of transportation on
Earth in all of Dragon Ball I'm serious
about that by the way this Magic Carpet
thing he has puts the Instant
Transmission to shame on planet Earth
dude can teleport in an instant without
even a key signature to lock onto but
something I didn't notice until this
reread was how both the saner as well as
this one begins with stories of an alien
origin both Goku and Kami children send
from their respective homeworlds to wait
for rescue on an alien planet with both
infant suffering memory loss in the
process and to be honest when I first
read this I found the Amnesia angle to
be quite convoluted and frankly a little
convenient considering we already just
moments prior except that that was
Goku's fate also and while it is a
little trite for it to follow a similar
path in that regard let's see if there's
something more at play here thematically
to acknowledge before casting harsh
judgment
put it up
structurally or narratively this plot
Point exists to grind Bulma Krillin and
Gohan the means with which to travel
dynamic in order to make their wish on
the namekian Dragon Balls before Vegeta
does because of this there's a pressing
time constraint and thus they couldn't
wait for Goku who eventually travels
using his own pods Tech and otherwise
creative Choice that's difficult to
critique in comparison however with Goku
and Kami sharing a similar origin in
many respects there's something more
very thematically perhaps to appreciate
divulged initially through Mr Popo and
later on Namek itself we hear a tale of
a mysterious event on that planet called
the cataclysm an event that almost wiped
out the namekian race entirely not too
dissimilar to Goku's fated Homeworld
Planet Vegeta however unlike Goku who
arrived with the mission of destroying
Humanity itself ultimately thanks to the
kindness of one individual he survived a
terrible fall and became a sweet and
loving child conversely the son of
catat's Kami thanks to the harshness of
his time spent waiting endlessly on
earth and the evils of humanity itself
was forced to purge himself of this
learned Darkness resulting in King
Piccolo of whom we're all familiar with
the earth's greatest threat two similar
paths both resulting in polar opposite
outcomes for Goku and kame the cataclysm
is described as a sudden but significant
change in the climate that took Namek to
the brink leaving only one namekian
behind perhaps a thematic forewarning of
a similarly powerful force of nature a
certain emperor of the universe that
threatens their very existence of both
the recovering Planet Namek and its
people and speaking of unlike Vegeta and
Raditz whom we see at the very end of
the First Act no such treatment is given
to Frieza his name is treated with far
more reverence or fear perhaps upon
Vegeta's return to receive Medical
Treatments while the condition he's seen
in is viewed as surprising and the
Saiyan Prince is given respect for from
those beneath him Frieza despite not
even being present is still a name that
appears from the mouths of almost
everyone in the facility on a number of
occasions each individual even Vegeta
seems to Grant this name this ruler the
attention and respect He commands as far
as preludes to an instruction goes this
is surprisingly effective particularly
because it's paired with Vegeta's
motivation for the arc and his role
being established he is neither the main
threat nor the sight of good instead
acting as an enemy yes but also the
enemy of our enemy as he operates
somewhere in the middle between the two
poles of this story The earthlings and
Frieza and finally one last tidbit
before we move on to the main meat of
this Arc I mentioned in my review of the
Saiyan Saga that Vegeta in his mind
represented the perfect Saiyan
genetically Superior to Goku in every
way regardless of his allegiances and
hard work he was the self-professed
strongest in the universe and everyone
thinks they're the strongest in the
universe there's never a need to learn
anything from anyone because well
they're inferior however the First Act
to this Arc demonstrates that Vegeta
following his Retreat on Earth has
learned something has taken away a piece
of knowledge when offered his scouter
before departing for Namek Vegeta
declines it's a very small moment
restricted to one panel alone but in it
you could already see the wheels put in
motion for the journey Vegeta is about
to Embark upon
foreign
in the previous Arc I praised the story
for its wonderful use and introduction
of the B plot no longer was Goku the
sole Focus for the story's second act
instead the Limelight was shared with
Gohan and Piccolo as they too prepared
for the Saiyans and it seems as though
Toriyama either received praise for this
choice or simply enjoyed it tremendously
because where the Saiyan Saga leveraged
the benefits of two separate plot
threads The namik Saga doubled it to
four plot threads and in the process
created the single most compelling and
in my opinion complex stretch of Dragon
Ball story both to date and arguably
ever the Scramble for the namekian
Dragon Balls is a detailed web of
various groups and stressors all with
different conflicting ideologies goals
and methods coming into dramatic
conflict with one another and outside of
a couple missteps I think it's an
incredibly exciting success in terms of
writing for Akira Toriyama particularly
when you consider he hadn't really tried
anything like this before in the same
way the name material is notorious for
being both exciting and dense in terms
of narrative for people to cover you've
got everything from the earthlings
peaceful arrival to their discovery of a
great evil they must avoid at all costs
meanwhile we've got Vegeta making his
sophomore outing with the series this
time as the proverbial thorn in the
sight of pretty much everyone who isn't
Vegeta and finally we have the single
most intimidating entity ever to be
introduced in this now wide expansive
Story the emperor of the universe Frieza
on his quest to wish for immortality the
one thing his seemingly unlimited power
hasn't been able to Grant him yet the
reason why I highlight the story as
these groups to analyze is because I'd
like to emphasize the enormous Gap in
difficulty between training arcs
occurring in parallel during the lead-up
to the Saiyan Invasion and this chaotic
exciting mishmash of power strategies
personalities and fighting that may
makes up this section of the material
it's like advancing from B plots for
dummies to The Song of Ice and Fire
novels seamlessly and due to this added
complexity in order for me to
effectively break it down I've had to
reconstruct how I present this material
to prevent it from being a simple
step-by-step breakdown of each event
that's boring and I want to do better
than that so instead I've decided to
break down this impressive section as
follows there are three main groups in
this section the earthlings Frieza and
finally Vegeta each group I'll touch on
in this section is represented by a
particular ideology and keeping that in
mind is honestly the secret sauce that
makes this section of the story tick
examining the differences in how team
Earth team Frieza and team Vegeta carry
themselves is key to not only
understanding how these Dynamics work
and pay off but moreover how this ended
up creating some of the best and most
exciting sequences in this series and it
all starts with
the earthlings arrival
each group is set apart by something
fundamental to them whether that be fear
greed or altruism in the case of Team
Earth composed of Gohan Bulma and
Krillin as they blindly step forth into
the stars and onto a brand new alien
world Namek not for themselves not for
their greed but explicitly for others
and surprisingly no other character
exemplifies this trait of altruism more
than Son Gohan and to tell you the truth
it's quite meaningful all things
considered when you take a closer look
as he sat there banged up in the
hospital following the same Invasion
while being coddled by his loving mother
Gohan demonstrates how he's grown as a
person tremendously there and then gone
are the days of the once Meek and
terrified of his own shadow little kid
and now stands a young man with a
considerable sense of responsibility for
those he loves and respects straight up
disobeying his mother's explicit orders
to not get involved in this rescue going
on to deliver a surprisingly heroic
speech the likes of which you'd never
see Goku deliver outside of a dove
rewrite talking about the responsibility
he feels to do the right thing by those
that gave up their own lives for the
Earth how he has the power to do
something and therefore should it being
the only way he can bring Piccolo back
and when he says all of this it's
difficult not to hear the final parting
words Gohan shared with Piccolo echo in
the background this is all to say that
the leading inspiration for the
earthlings is their conscience their
desire to do the right thing despite
being faced with seemingly
insurmountable odds
[Music]
okay so not good and this is about as
good a time as any to illustrate that
tenacity and a kind heart isn't going to
cut it if they are going to survive on
the single most dangerous planet filled
with the universe's most Savage Killers
for long and so this is a perfect spot
to point out their unique approach when
it comes to navigating this world
they're entirely passive if they can
help it and that approach honestly
turned this Rescue of dende into one of
the best scenes for me in the first half
of this Arc something that often gets
overshadowed and in my case for the
first few times I read this totally
missed was the path that Gohan and
Krillin took in order to get to this
Village and witness what happens with
Frieza and his goons because that path
tells us a lot about them as characters
as shown earlier Gohan and Krillin
ultimately want to get in make their
wish and get out without being noticed
they have no desire for conflict and so
now the question for Toriyama is how can
I get these guys into conflict well it's
explicitly told to us that freeze his
men and Vegeta are seeking out the
Dragon Balls based on the villagers that
they are sensing using the inhabitants
as beacons for the Dragon Balls before
slaughtering them and stealing what they
came for that's what we as audience
members understand and know however due
to their nature as Frieza and his goons
fly overhead without so much as a dragon
radar in hand it doesn't even occur to
Gohan and Krillin that Frieza and his
men are targeting these Villages this
way resulting in once they arrive on the
scene to see how they are going about
business Gohan's true nature and shock
is exposed and in the process exposes
them to the dangers of Frieza and more
importantly dedoria right now it's a
small choice but honestly a massively
effective one that said I'd be remiss if
I didn't draw attention to issues I had
with this story too an aspect of this
tale that serves a clear and frankly
obvious narrative purpose but comes at
the cost of my own immersion in this
story is one that forced me to audibly
say oh really while I was reading
because I honestly didn't remember this
happening so here's the current
situation Akira Toriyama needs to give
the Earth things more of an edge in this
tale because let's be honest they're all
a gunned outnumbered and behind in the
search for the dragon balls and are
working with an impossible disadvantage
their tactics and kindness might have
landed them the benefit of dende their
inside man that can give them
suggestions and information but outside
of that they're very much behind in
every single sense of the word so to
remedy this Toriyama decided to allow
the earthlings to get the drop on Vegeta
first without him noticing meaning they
know he's there but he doesn't know that
they're on Namek this favors their
approach of sneaking around and puts
Vegeta in one aspect at a disadvantage
however in order to achieve that
Advantage this happens
[Music]
dude
oh my God no way yeah yeah I have to ask
what are the odds of a giant fish
jumping out of the water like that in
that exact moment considering it never
happened again in the series up until
then everything about this scene made
sense Gohan and Krillin could hide their
key and then they couldn't and thus
Vegeta was lured in to investigate it
all made sense however thanks to Moby
[__] over here Vegeta moves along as
if there's nothing to see here this
scene is entertainingly tense and offers
a lot to leverage in the future for the
earthlings but I can't help but feel how
contrived a creative choice that this
ultimately was I mean if this never
happened Vegeta wouldn't have hit his
Dragon Ball or taken as many chances
which led to Gohan and KO stealing some
of his unlike Gohan's tale returning in
the prior episode in the nick of time
towards the end of the story this one
acts as an anchoring point that future
key plot elements need to rely on now
don't get me wrong I'm thrilled with all
that occurs later in this story I just
don't like this one scene it sort of
sours what comes later ever so slightly
and unfortunately it doesn't stop there
chapters later dende brings Krillin to
guru's place in order to gain precious
Intel retrieve his Dragon Ball and to
unlock his true power now let's look at
this closely there's plenty to love
about this Choice thematically it's been
explained already that the namekian
Dragon Balls upon request are given to
Heroes with good hearts that they must
pass challenges Etc and thus it makes
sense that given the circumstances Guru
would give Krillin the Dragon Ball It's
a Wonderful peaceful contrast to how
Frieza and Vegeta have gathered theirs
putting greater emphasis on krillin's
Good Intentions all the while helping to
level the playing field slightly and
while still lopsided it is now starting
to turn in the right direction for the
earthlings it's wonderful and it all
takes place because they made The
Virtuous choice in Saving dende by
risking their own lives however and you
knew that however was coming Guru
possessing the power to boost the
Earthling strength or should I say
release their hidden power feels uh
contrived I said the same thing in my
review for the King Piccolo are
concerning Corin Tower and the Magical
water Goku drank that made him stronger
and I've just never been a fan of
unearned power-ups although this type of
thing has now been established in this
world and therefore at least having some
semblance of setup I just don't think
two wrongs make a right unfortunately
you could argue in this instance the
earthlings have earned this power up by
doing the right thing time and again and
I suppose that does make this pill
easier to swallow but it still feels
kind of cheap like a kiritoriyama saw
the widening gap between the earthlings
and literally everyone else on this
proverbial chessboard and decided to
give them an extra Queen because he felt
sorry for them or perhaps more
accurately because they'd stand no
chance against anything else on the
horizon if he didn't particularly given
how insane things are going to get with
regards power Creek later on however
before that happens the fact the
earthings got the drop in Vegeta early
is about to pay off in another one of
these very intense exchanges
ha ha Street
Akira toriyama's ultimate plan for sun
Gohan is constantly making its presence
felt all throughout this Arc using the
radar Gohan locates Vegeta's Hidden
Dragon Ball at the bottom of a lake and
even comparing his demeanor to the
beginning of the Last Arc demonstrates a
colossal change in his character so much
more confident much less childish so
much more responsibility on the surface
and moreover he doesn't shrink In the
Heat of the Moment either confronted by
Vegeta who couldn't have been more scary
to him in the arc prior he stands his
ground puts on his best poker face and
successfully absorbs a strike from him
even going on to smile afterwards
because he knows that he won the war as
long as they have one Dragon Ball
they're all in a stalemate no matter how
strong the other side might be
[Music]
team Frieza frieza's introduction to the
story is additionally our first
introduction to their squad and
therefore the second party I'm examining
today sharing many similarities to the
chilling opening sequence of Quentin
Tarantino's Inglorious Bastards this
introduction alongside another creepy
customer I'll be touching on next week
holds for me the title of best
introduction in the series and if I'm
being honest I think this one might just
Edge it out Frieza demonstrates his
control not just of many dragon balls or
his powerful henchmen but also the lives
of the poor defenseless demekian elders
and children that even suggest that they
might stand in his way of what he wants
sitting comfortably atop his floating
Throne hardly lifting so much as a
single finger he relishes in taking the
path that will cause the most emotional
damage to his opponent no matter what it
seems exemplified perhaps no better than
this scene where the village Elder tells
the small children behind him to run
away while he holes freezer off
[Applause]
these were the events that caused
Gohan's Outburst caused him to blow
their cover and led to doria's pursuit
in the first place but moreover this is
our introduction to Frieza and his team
and regrettably this is the team's
approach after having explored the
earthlings tactics it seems in many
respects the exact opposite approach is
taken by team Frieza not passive in the
slightest and operating in broad
daylight this monster fears no one
demanding he gets what he wants directly
without so much as the need to lift a
single finger if he doesn't want to all
the while the earthlings try to keep low
profiles stealing and sneaking small
victories here and there where they can
Frieza and his team literally bulldozed
their way through Namek using their
Superior Tech and Powers however as
exposited in the prior Arc this Superior
Tech combined with their philosophy of
Might makes ripe leads them to have a
very clear and obvious weakness one that
the earthlings could use to their
advantage and
are about to exploit
[Music]
[Applause]
naturally we don't spend as much time
with the likes of Frieza and his team as
we do with the earthlings in Vegeta
however I'd argue that this is part of
what makes them feel so in control and
formidable throughout this entire
sequence despite the doria's suspicious
absence and eventually zarbons too
Frieza never loses sight of his ultimate
goal to gather the namekian Dragon Balls
even after registering the presence of
other forces on the planet in the shape
of Vegeta and even the earthlings
themselves he's only ever really thrown
when his ultimate goal is compromised or
encounters speed bumps the loss of
zarvin and the Doria almost feels
secondary to the reaction he offers
after losing the scouters you can see
the quiet rage like someone just got the
upper hand of them that he didn't expect
and get the upper hand they did without
these he'll struggle to locate more
Dragon Balls throughout this opening
sequence he loses to Doria he loses kiwi
he loses Vegeta technically he loses
zarbon and many others he uses them all
and he just ships in more with new and
improved scouters they're just meat
Shields to him the limits of his
inhumanity and cruelty seemingly show no
signs of limitation and the most
unsettling part is he hasn't come in
direct conflict with anyone of
consequence in the story yet but we
still feel his everlooming presence over
the story like a specter he feels
Unstoppable in one-on-one confrontation
the earthlings know it and most
importantly our third team or should I
say in Prince knows it too
blue
[Music]
team Vegeta in many ways Vegeta is the
single most important character in this
section of the story while the likes of
Frieza and the earthlings share very
little in terms of approach thus making
their coming into contact rather rare
and tricky to bring about Vegeta is very
much the gel that holds and connects
these teams together looking at this
through a narrative Theory lens Vegeta
is a perfect hybrid of the two teams we
just spoke about while he will leverage
savagery intimidation and force when
necessary like Frieza he knows that
presently he is best served by picking
and choosing his moments carefully so as
not to overextend himself it's here we
get to enjoy the Strategic and
intelligent Vegeta from the Saiyan Saga
one where we finally begin to stop
looking at him as just an adversary but
more closely as someone to follow along
with we understand his despicable
reprehensible and bad to the bone made
evident by his treatment of a certain
namekian Village but it's in these
moments we can see his utility to the
earthlings and even start to appreciate
his tenacity cunning and strategy when
applied against the likes of Frieza and
his men that represent the truest sense
of evil in this galaxy I touched on this
in the past however while the earthlings
are the side that we find ourselves
cheering for we can't help but get
caught up in the Cavalcade of mischief
and Terror Vegeta exacts on the world
around him and I often wondered why I
found it so exciting and the answer I
stumbled across was well in storytelling
there are two modes characters can often
find themselves operating with and
largely these dictate how interesting
they ultimately are within a story these
two modes are settings a character can
be set to are active and reactionary
when we look at the earthlings they are
largely a reactionary Force as of right
now trying to move undetected and
passively achieve their goals by
reacting to the movements of other more
powerful fighters on Planet Namek
however they aren't exclusively this way
and it's in those short bursts of active
participation where they make their own
choices that dictate the story that we
find the most exciting as viewers Vegeta
is the exact opposite of the earthlings
in this respect Vegeta is probably the
most active character in the story and
in many ways makes this story happen
where Frieza demonstrates the Pinnacle
of the hierarchy Vegeta simply laughs
and using his power intimidation and
intelligence bends the world around him
to his will sure he'll exhibit bursts of
reactionary Tendencies by targeting
isolated goons like dodoria kiwi and
zarbon but he'll also leverage
apparently terrible circumstances and
transform them into some of the most
exciting double crosses that will have
you at the edge of your seat actually
cheering him on because you're so
impressed by what he's managed to
achieve with effectively nothing but
good timing some power and a few staunch
Bluffs acting as the soul force in the
story that forces the earthlings to act
as well as team Frieza to lash out
at this point everything seems to be
going Vegeta's way he's stolen all of
the Dragon Balls in frieza's possession
in the heist of the century he's stolen
the Dragon Ball Krillin received from
Guru because he was being careless with
his own power boost furthermore Vegeta
himself has had numerous additional
zenkai boosts making him one of the
strongest beings on the planet itself
and in addition to all of that he now
has seven dragon balls in his possession
he even got to beat up kakarot's little
kid who was just randomly chilling out
on his own everything is great all he
has to do now is grab the first ball
that he hid away under a leg after he
slaughtered that Village should be
around here somewhere
could have sworn wait
honestly without Vegeta this first
section of the arc wouldn't be nearly as
amazing as it otherwise is and what
makes it even better following the
explosion of anger towards the
earthlings getting the drop on him he's
forced to swallow his pride and join
forces as a certain flamboyant fighting
force ordered to the planet by Frieza
for backup arrives and what's more is
the arrival of this fighting force
changes the entire Dynamic of this Arc
no longer are we dealing with scattered
teams and chaotic plot threads now we
are contending with unlikely alliances
fighting for survival against beings
that are some of the most cruel in the
galaxy
foreign
[Music]
Gohan and Krillin versus guldo I've
praised Akira toriyama's paneling Ad
nauseam over the years and I certainly
will continue to do so shut up but I
think if there was ever a moment his
creativity was held back by his layouts
it was in this fight with guldo the
artwork and paneling is still crisp as
ever as you would expect from this era
of the story but while he's dealing with
static images as a foundation to his
work I don't think conveying guldo's
power of stopping time was particularly
effective visually here which is why I
think he felt the urge for guldo to
consistently monologue about what he's
doing and what he's thinking moment to
moment it feels very unnatural and
unlike any other dialogue in the story
and interestingly or perhaps fittingly
the best part of this fight isn't the
fighting itself but the pre-fight hype
up from Vegeta to Krillin and Gohan
along with his assist at the end it
honestly makes you believed he's on your
side rather than against you this time
it's a wonderful feeling furthermore you
can see his trademark strategic approach
permeate every piece of dialogue and
action he offers throwing the Dragon
Ball away ordering Krillin to break it
taking stock of his team and when Goku
is expected to arrive you can tell he's
constantly thinking of ways to tip the
scales in his favor he feels like a real
living and breathing character even
criticizing Gohan and krillin's choice
in approach mid-battle and to be quite
honest without Vegeta the Ginyu Force
themselves wouldn't be nearly as
intimidating all of their intensity and
characterization that's worth anything
comes from Vegeta's dialogue concerning
them and how they force Vegeta out of
his active role and into a reactionary
one
oh
my God I love Vegeta
Vegeta versus raccoon I don't know what
there's to say about this fight that
already hasn't been said to death the
choreography is stunning the build up is
Sublime the circumstances are fittingly
dire and Vegeta is ruthless we even get
a preview of the technique that would
eventually become the Final Flash in
this fight something else I do enjoy
about this though that isn't brought up
enough I think is that while Vegeta is
amazingly helpful in the guldo fight
both before and after Even In the Heat
of this battle against raccoon at no
point does he ever expect to receive
assistance from anyone he scratches he
claws and cheap shots where he can and
when he exhausts himself staring down
raccoon's final attack he says to
himself in his mind that he's going to
die the earthlings go on to save Vegeta
but the means with which they did made
me reflect on Vegeta's method of making
the save prior on them he quite
literally didn't try to save them he
tried to kill guldo saving them was
incidental Gohan and Krillin had to
dodge on their own once they were free
when Gohan saves Vegeta the Saiyan
Prince reprimands him for not making the
Strategic play instead of the
sentimental one but it's not all bad
news it seems at least not yet while
Frieza has all of the dragon balls he is
unable to use them specifically because
of who he is and what he stands for as
the story explained earlier the namekian
dragon balls are normally given to
Heroes with righteous Hearts after
passing a series of compelling
challenges the very nature of this
challenge seems in line with something
classic Dragon Ball would explore
however frieza's presence saw fit to
Sure change that possible Adventure in
the name of a much darker and serious
tale thankfully however the namekians
had a Fail-Safe precaution built into
the Dragon Balls themselves one the
likes of Frieza and the approach he has
taken would never in a million years
receive a password one that Frieza does
not have specifically because of his
brutal approach and while things seem to
be going from bad to worse in the
battlefield against raccoon with Vegeta
Krillin and now Gohan taking either
Serious injury or being taken out
completely at the very last possible
moment he arrives
foreign
[Music]
Goku arrives
a character I've not spoken of enough in
this video is Goku surprising as that
might be but Goku really isn't the focus
of the story that he used to be and
that's mostly because the way Dragon
Ball story is told from this point on is
honestly very different to the arcs that
preceded it
oh
for he once shared a lot of the
spotlight with other characters in the
sand Arc this nameic material has him
omitted almost entirely while he travels
to Namek following his friends we really
only see him through brief cutaways that
serve to remind us on occasion that he
does in fact still exist and is getting
stronger quite a bit stronger but don't
worry that lack of screen time that
inactivity that changes here briefly but
after that he's back right it kinda
that's next week's problem what's
happened with Goku and Namek well tell
you the truth it's kind of awesome I
remember watching this moment unfold as
a kid Goku arrives right after Gohan
sustains a devastating injury through
raccoon breaking the little kid's neck
it's honestly one of the most unsettling
sights in the anime when it happens but
that unsettling feeling is contrasted
beautifully with Goku's emphatic return
to the spotlight but as I alluded to
moments ago unlike his timely return to
the Battlefield on Earth during the
Saiyan Saga this occasion feels
distinctly different and well almost
unique when compared to both The Last
Arc and the greater Series this might be
the most seismic change in Dragon Ball
storytelling approach since the
conclusion of the very first Arc and its
eventual pivot to the Kung Fu tournament
style that lasted all the way up until
the end of the Saiyan Saga and with the
Namek Saga but more specifically the
arrival of Goku on Namek it's clear
we've entered a brand new era of the
show one that brandishes a specific
change and that change is pushing past
your limits instead of chronicling the
virtues of martial arts training in a
Kung Fu series we are concerning
ourselves more now with the scope of the
battles themselves the characters
involved in how they continuously push
past their respective limits during said
battles and to be clear I'm not saying
that one is superior than the other but
instead pointing out the shift that's
taking place instead I spoke briefly
earlier on the topic of Krillin and
Gohan receiving sudden power boosts
instead of going through a training Arc
to remain competitive in the mix of
combat but that's just the tip of the
iceberg here where the previews Arc
placed all of its emphasis on
self-improvement through technique and
camaraderie that was ultimately explored
in the final battle thematically this
Arc flips that concept on its head
focusing instead and overcoming one's
physical limits through sheer will and
determination alone whether that be via
Goku subjecting himself to brutal
gravity training on the way Dynamic
Gohan and Krillin align themselves with
the namekians in order to get stronger
or Vegeta just by simply being too angry
to die partnered up with his new best
friend the zenkai Boost the mountain
that is being climbed metaphorically
over the course of this Arc is certainly
a different one than which was explored
during the Saiyan material and following
the climax of that Arc in many respects
part of me is pleased they pivoted in
this direction for Frieza mostly because
I genuinely can't imagine a better way
to conclude that particular era of
Dragon Ball and the final story told
between the prince from the stars and
the outcast from Earth and while part of
me does lament the Change of Atmosphere
even I have to admit the clear benefits
narratively to this change in Creative
Direction namely
[Applause]
the myth of the Legendary Super Saiyan
I've been carefully measuring my
Approach when breaking down the Scramble
for the Dragon Balls here and it's for a
reason choosing to highlight the
interactions and convergences between
three teams with contrasting Dynamics
the passive earthlings the cunning
Vegeta and the assertive and domineering
immovable object that is Frieza his
approach is simple confront head on and
take what you want when you want with
malice and interestingly as Goku struts
onto the battlefield aiding his allies
taking out raccoons styling on Jace and
taking out burger with ease his approach
and role in this Arc too becomes Crystal
Clear he's not passive and nor is he
cunning it's entirely direct an approach
that was significantly more peaceful
makes him structurally the perfect
natural counter to Frieza up until now
Frieza has been a force the likes of
which cannot be denied and now as we
noticed through Goku's battle with the
Ginyu Force he too possesses an aura
that is undeniable one that forces the
Gin use to blurt out in fear wondering
if Goku could be the legend that they've
heard of the Super Saiyan both Frieza
and Goku are now on a fixed path for
conflict in the ark and one you can feel
the tension for right away what happens
when an Unstoppable Force meets the
immovable object
this is awesome but the the arrival of
Goku is also significant because it
marks the convergence of several
long-running plot threads the earthlings
Vegeta Frieza and indeed even Goku into
one wonderful cocktail of combat and
misdirection Goku's arrival very much is
the midpoint of the narrative and just
like with most midpoints of stories it
shakes things up considerably changing
the Status Quo while also providing a
significant swerve that changes our
perception of where this story is going
goju someone this now this scene might
seem rather inconsequential compared to
everything else serving only to keep
Frieza busy trying to figure out the
password to the Dragon Ball So Vegeta
can steal them back later with Gohan and
Krillin and while it does all of those
things it also forced me to do maths as
a kid in this brief scene Frieza Reveals
His battle power to be 530
000 before fighting nail and what's
interesting about that becomes apparent
when you look at it alongside the fight
Goku's enjoying showing off against
Ginyu for when leveraging the output of
a Kaioken times two Goku is shown to
boast a power level reading of 180
000 meaning that his base is ninety
thousand furthermore if we cast our
minds back to one of the few scenes we
see of Goku on the ship to Namek he said
he should be capable of managing a times
10 multiplier through the Kaioken thanks
to his intense training meaning his true
max around this time should sit
somewhere around 900 000 without
destroying himself too badly and more
than that if he really goes nuclear like
he did on Earth therefore this reveal
from Frieza places a considerable amount
of emphasis on two aspects of their
future fight Goku's capability to push
past his limits and the extent to which
frieza's transformation according to
zarbonne can offer him in terms of a
power boost also however all things
considered at this moment in time while
Frieza is monstrous things seem to be
within reach for Goku well that is until
the midpoints were I touched on earlier
when that comes into effect things
change
and
[Applause]
I think as a kid this was a section of
the story that bothered me beyond
measure it was such a cheap trick such a
cheap shot one that put Goku into the
worst position he's been in since the
end of The Last Arc and one that totally
ruins what had been up until that point
Goku styling on virtually everyone he
came into contact with and while there's
very clearly some terrific opportunities
for the likes of Krillin and especially
Gohan and Vegeta to flex their
character's finest attributes when
facing such demonstrably strange and
troubling circumstances it stands to
reason that this scene and sequence
exists for no other reason than to take
Goku out of commission for the
foreseeable future until he's ready to
join the main offensive against Frieza
later on in terms of pacing intention
for the story this is a fine and Natural
Choice to make allow the tension to
Fester as the likes of Gohan and Krillin
prepare for frieza's imminent arrival
following Nails Revelation 2 Frieza that
is likely too late and while this might
be the FUNimation filler kid in me
talking after spend ending what felt
like two years waiting for Goku to get
out of that goddamn tank reading through
this comparatively reasonably short
sequence of chapters waiting for him to
get out only helped to resurface the
trauma that was waiting for that stupid
tank to let Goku out okay but again I
think that is just the childhood anime
viewer in me resurfacing because as is
the case with many things that drag on
in Dragon Ball Z it's paced much better
in the manga
be the first time in literal days the
two earthlings summoned the namekian
dragon with the help of den day this is
a perfect choice for these two
characters to make in this moment in
time however
remember when I said that nail started
snickering at Frieza claiming that it
was likely too late for him to make his
wish now because dende must have already
given the earthlings the password yeah
well I gotta ask
why did he say that I mean he's lying
there limp on the ground with his only
Mission being to stall for time he knows
the dragon hasn't been summoned yet he's
flat on his back so the only thing he
can see is this guy is the sky darknail
no then shut the [__] up it's a nitpick
but why tell him there and then why not
just wait for this guy to go all dark
and then say it oh wait I know why
foreign
if there's one aspect of this story I
hope is abundantly clear it's that Akira
Toriyama knows how to tie his themes to
the final fights exceptionally well with
regards to the Saiyan Invasion the story
of that material saw the weaker
earthlings demonstrate that Natural Born
strength alone isn't the only thing that
matters in a fight to communicate this
Toriyama created the characters of
Vegeta and Napa to bounce off of two
entities that epitomize this idea of
Might makes right ruthless aggression
and natural born ability all the while
the earthlings efforts were framed such
that they relied on training technique
and the bonds they forged across this
entire journey in other words they were
the ideological opposites to that of the
Saiyans making the final battle not
simply a compelling fight between some
awesome characters but also a battle
between two sides of an argument two
sides that explored that arcs themes the
Frieza Saga as I mentioned has changed
up the formula somewhat however the to
say the same structure approach isn't
taken by Toriyama when we approach the
final section of this story
[Music]
foreign
Vegeta's approach here Ally himself
alongside the likes of the earthlings in
an effort to topple the greatest evil
and power this story has ever seen the
themes of camaraderie and martial arts
are less of a force in this exchange
there's a compelling story being told
about pushing past your limits in this
Arc one that for the longest time could
easily be applied to the likes of Goku
Piccolo Gohan Krillin and even Vegeta
all in very different ways Goku by
continuously exposing himself to
torturous gravity training bringing him
to the brink of death over and over
again on Route Dynamic Piccolo accepting
the help of a stranger to gain the
strength necessary to help Gohan Krillin
getting his hidden power released and
then we have Vegeta and Gohan two
characters who perhaps demonstrate this
theme of pushing past your limits more
than any other characters in this Arc so
far so much so you'd be hard-pressed to
find an argument that says that these
two aren't the main characters of this
nemic material prior to the final battle
while the term pushing past your limits
has lost 95 percent of its meaning in
the modern material referring only to
the effort and power you can emit from
your person these days which is kind of
in line with the Saiyan saga's bad
themes but whatever in this act both
Vegeta and Gohan while pushing
themselves physically in increasingly
dangerous and Reckless ways to achieve
their respective goals there's also
another dimension to this limit breaking
theme that you might not be considering
when it comes to Vegeta's actions in
this Arc you'd be hard-pressed to find
anyone that doesn't recall his epic
clashes against the likes of frieza's
henchmen whether it be his beatdowns of
kiwi and dodoria his cunning struggle
against zarban or his catastrophic Clash
against raccoon and the rest of the
ginyus it's abundantly clear that Vegeta
has pushed past his limits physically
time and time again a fact he reminds us
of every other chapter when he recovers
from the brink of death but often
overlooked are the compromises Vegeta
makes the harsh truths he must have had
to consider Twitter and the options he
took following his defeat on planet
Earth and during the events of Namek as
this situation worsens the character
Vegeta was during the Saiyan Saga the
type that wouldn't see the value in
learning anything from anyone the
self-professed most powerful in the
universe is no longer here during this
Frieza Saga and in many ways this is
because he's no longer allowing his
pride to rule his life he willingly
learns to sense Ki without the aid of a
scouter and he joins forces with the
earthlings who forced him to retreat
while he has indeed pushed past his
limits physically it should also be
apparent that Vegeta 2 has pushed past
the limits of his own Pride to achieve
more favorable outcomes for himself I
mentioned in my last video that Dragon
Ball Z isn't simply the story of Goku in
isolation anymore but is becoming
increasingly more so the rise of Son
Gohan and I think this Arc emphasizes
this creative change even more so while
I think The Narrative of the Saiyan Saga
offered Gohan a lot to work with from a
character standpoint the story itself
was still very much contingent on the
past actions of Goku how the bonds his
force and the attitude he possesses
towards self-improvement served him
greatly in the battle against Vegeta
however this Arc shifts that approach to
one that's more internally driven
character by character one that Goku can
still and will largely continue to
participate in to Legendary degrees as
this story presses forward but one
that's also I believe Taylor Made for
the likes of sun Gohan to demonstrate
the very best of his character when you
stop to ask yourself the question what
does Gohan value more than anything else
when we first see the character that
seems obvious like all children his age
they value security and their own
self-interest he is just a small naive
child after all however as we saw in the
Saiyan Saga Gohan values his allies
tremendously when faced with Piccolo's
death he lashes out at Napa with great
power what he notices the fake moon in
the sky he's the one that insists they
turn back to help his dad not Krillin
what his mom told him to stay he
insisted to go and when dende was about
to die all alone Gohan proved that as
long as he has a pulse he's always
willing to do what he thinks is the
right thing this small child might be
naive and inexperienced as Vegeta says
but he has an enormous amount of heart
and thanks to friends like Krillin who
bring that level of experience up on his
side they are able to pick up the slack
when Gohan overextends himself Beyond
his own capabilities which takes a lot
while Gohan Goku and Vegeta are all in
similar situations regarding Frieza as
has been established throughout this
Tale the same blood within these
characters pays off tremendously in ways
unforeseen even by the likes of Frieza
Gohan is still a brave character for all
the reasons I mentioned but I'd like to
illustrate just How brave Krillin is two
at every turn the battlefields Gohan has
been on Krillin has been there to watch
Gohan's back every single step of the
way when he falls Krillin picks him up
and even here when Frieza carelessly
demonstrates a fraction of his power to
show off Krillin doesn't think about
himself but instead risks his life once
again
to protect dende and it costs him
[Music]
in the manga when Krillin is impaled by
the Despicable Frieza for no other
reason than his own morbid Amusement
while the heroic nature of Krillin
saving dende led to this outcome for the
young man it's the reactions of both
Vegeta and Gohan I found particularly
interesting acting as projections for us
to observe as to where their respective
priorities lie for Vegeta it's power
shouting out in amazement of the speed
Frieza was capable of totally
dispassionate towards krillin's fated
outcome all the while Gohan screams his
friend's name reflecting the humanity
that's being drained from his best
friend right before his eyes earlier in
this Arc while Vegeta had to make
decisions in plays he might not be proud
of Gohan for the duration of this Arc is
totally and entirely outside of his
comfort zone terrified exposed the
reprehensible actions of others
physically abused tricked and eventually
forced to watch on as his best friend
has his life drained from him since the
introduction action of sun Gohan as a
character in the prior Arc while other
characters have been able to push
themselves physically to achieve their
desired outcomes able to leverage their
strengths and lean upon the heroics that
save them time and again in the past
this story for Gohan has not been about
how heroic he is but instead his journey
to find the hero that lies within him
when it comes to pushing past his limits
what it's clear to see he's done so time
and again on a physical level it's the
emotional maturity of this character as
he's forced to push past the limitations
of his mental state that two provides
for me some of the most compelling set
pieces in this Arc as a whole without
hesitation flying to the rescue of
Krillin Frieza appears before the young
child with a simple taunting statement
why don't you worry about your own life
foreign
say what you want about what this
character manages to pull off later in
the arc or what he's done before but no
other scene in this Arc or the prior one
reflects Gohan as a character better
than this one's snapshot in time facing
down the literal devil of the universe
someone he knows he is absolutely no
chance against
someone who terrifies him beyond measure
he doesn't even acknowledge what he says
he probably doesn't even hear it all
he's able to register is someone or
something in his way and the fading
light of Krillin extinguishing before
his very eyes before exclaiming move at
the top of his lungs and unloading
everything he's got on Frieza there and
then a child of no more than five years
of age with virtually no training was
able to level the first significant
attack onto Frieza we've seen in the
entire Series in his second form no less
it's one of my favorite scenes from this
anime one that demonstrates exactly the
sort of character Gohan is and once
again alludes us to where this story is
ultimately going
path that will brutalize him torture him
both physically and mentally test his
limits in every sense of the word as
he's forced to stand feigning fearlessly
against the likes of Frieza scrambling
screaming to get back to his feet only
to be beaten down time and again for the
little five-year-old kid no matter his
talents no matter his potential no
matter his seemingly endless reserves of
Courage the misery this monster is
dishing out is unmistakably going to be
the last thing he will ever see
[Applause]
treat people with kindness and they will
be kind to you
train with people and they will stand by
you risk your life for another without
hesitation and they too if you're lucky
will do the same for you and perfectly
poetically
isn't simply Gohan saving Krillin paying
off here but instead the compound
interest of two separate instances Gohan
has risked his life for another for in
addition to krillin's rescue I just
mentioned a moment ago it was his
initial Rescue of dende towards this
arc's beginning that not only made it
possible for the Dragon Balls to wish
Piccolo back to life and on Dynamic but
in addition to all of that made it
possible for Krillin to get up in the
first place for dende has the hidden
ability revealed by Guru to heal others
on the battlefield and man the look
Gohan levels against Frieza once he's
healed is next level after reading that
scene I had to look it up and man it
gives me chills to my spine every single
time
and as it happens this didn't Inspire
just me but the cunning and always
strategizing Saiyan prince who suddenly
feels that little bit more at ease
moments before
[Applause]
[Music]
if there's one aspect to this section of
the Frieza fight Toriyama does well it's
manage our expectations and create
hopeful moments of believable Joy given
that Goku hasn't been a massive or even
medium-sized part of this Actos far
showing up momentarily only to be
benched once again in that attack at
this point you'd believe that this was a
story following the likes of Vegeta and
Gohan and with Piccolo now after having
arrived in the land of his ancestors for
the very first time in his life it
should go without saying that her
attention here isn't lazily applied to
these battles thinking that they're
simply stalling for Goku but instead
we're in a believable sequence where
genuine Victory seems to always be
inches from our grasp and at no point
has this been more true than at this
very moment with a reinvigorated Vegeta
a zenkai boosted Gohan and the arrival
of one mighty warrior carrying with him
the hope and courage of an entire race
on the brink of Extinction and the fight
ensues once again gives us hope for
victory being right on the horizon a
fact even Vegeta seems to be astounded
by Frieza is monstrous but for the most
part throughout this material thus far
we've only seen him sit in a chair and
command his minions to do his dirty work
with him only recently deciding to flex
his own power and exercise his own will
onto those around him and it's for that
very reason we've not yet seen something
integral to the character of Frieza
we've not yet seen what he represents in
the story entirely yet and that is
complete and utter hopelessness for
despite this battle playing host to many
moments where our heroes and unlike the
Allies have become more physically
monstrous than in any other time before
demonstrating their own enormous amounts
of courage and heart and after having
broken their own limits time and again
in this very instance it's revealed what
Frieza truly is a vicious and sadistic
creature Without Limits
and what's more is even the hero we
await the triumphant return of Goku even
he thinks he might not be able to win
here even if he's healed completely this
is what Frieza is abject misery
pessimism and helplessness a famine a
plague on any world he finds in his
crosshairs he is the Emperor and the
most powerful entity in this universe
and whatever he wants his Limitless
strength wills it so the mighty namekian
warrior with the fate of his people on
his shoulders cannot topple this monster
the zenkai boosted Gohan despite once
again demonstrating tremendous promise
has no chance of success but where Braun
and heart has failed us Toriyama looks
to the Strategic Genius of Vegeta our
final pool of Hope from which to draw
from one whose hands are stained red in
the blood of the innocent we are forced
to place all our chips on his final
Gambit but even we at home feel like
this is the right thing to do Vegeta
always taking stock of his options and
resources deciding to leverage his
Saiyan genetics at the final hour before
Frieza reveals to all of us his final
form
[Music]
foreign
every time I watch this take place I
cannot help but think back to the moment
where Vegeta saves Gohan and Krillin
from guldo and Howling Gohan return that
same gesture Vegeta scolded him berated
him insulted his experience or locked
thereof for Vegeta never made a decision
based on sentiment before he never
intended to save Gohan and Krillin
necessarily in so far as he saw value in
them as useful idiots to help him regain
control of a particular situation
seizing the chance to kill gul'do and
leaving Gohan and Krillin to save
themselves if they could Vegeta makes a
variety of strategic plays in this Arc
famously some of the most ingenious in
the entire series however at this moment
when crafting what he believed to be a
foolproof plan one that took careful
precaution in the most unstable of
situations just like in his battle
against raccoon where Gohan saved him
Vegeta never saw the value in taking
into account the sentimentality and
feelings of others and this time
cost him had it not been for the
insistence of Piccolo and The Others
Vegeta would have died in the dust there
and then never to be remembered for
anything other than his own desperation
and abject cruelty but as fate would
have it as the dust Falls around a fully
realized emperor of the universe it
seems these terrible circumstances have
given rise to a brand new Super Saiyan
but
[Music]
now that Frieza has assumed his final
form and dende has been removed from the
battlefield thus creating a very real
sense of high-stakes drama Toriyama both
threw Vegeta's conviction and frieza's
haunting demeanor communicates to us
that something big is about to go down
that we are in fact approaching the
climax and interestingly this is a
battle I initially missed the obvious
parallels in much like the battle on
Earth against Napa these same Fighters
once again find themselves staring down
the barrel of a horrifying opponent in
the absence of Goku but this time it's
different Gohan leads the charge here no
longer the meek and defenseless child
this newly hardened Prodigy Furious over
the heartless murder of dende leads this
Trio's attack against Frieza and while
this battle of course does not amount to
a victory it represents an advancement
in Gohan's character and sets up a
fascinating callback to the previous Arc
with frieza's death being now headed
straight for him it's impossible not to
see Echoes of what led to Piccolo's
sacrifice but in spite of Piccolo's
presence he doesn't make the save nor is
Krillin the one who saves Gohan's life
here in a true reversal of the San Arc
this time it's Vegeta
foreign
[Music]
it's difficult not to feel a degree of
pity for Vegeta here off the back of a
zenkai boost this newfound strength
entirely convinces him he has become a
Super Saiyan as readers we all know
something so unceremonious would of
course never be the real deal not after
literally dozens of chapters of build up
and the concept is very quickly put to
bed here there's also an argument that
Vegeta's assault on Frieza here feels
too short in the manga that simply two
attacks doesn't quite cut it compared to
the anime's two episodes but I think it
worked in setting in the true Terror of
Frieza and setting up the genuinely
heartbreaking moment that follows Vegeta
with all of his strengths levees a blow
at Frieza only to be effortlessly dodged
what follows is an attack so fueled by
frustration and rage that its power
threatens the very Planet itself this is
his everything his final shot at
exacting revenge for his people and
it fails it breaks him
[Music]
reduce the tears incapable of speech
Vegeta's resolve is demolished and
Toriyama invokes a very rare instance of
mid-chapter narration Terror struck the
depths of Vegeta's soul for the first
time in his life
for the first time he felt despair for
the first time in his life
Vegeta shed tears the great Vegeta had
lost his will to fight what a phenomenal
piece of writing there is such a
dramatic shift in the way this segment
is told and fans of tagashi's Hunter
Hunter will be more than familiar with
it it pulls the audience right out of
the midst of the world and forces them
to take in the emotion of the event in a
way that is completely disconnected from
traditional manga storytelling this
sudden momentary ship provides a sudden
disembodied gravitas that just hits like
an atomic bomb here
Frieza the Limitless evil and boundless
dark cloud has stolen not only Vegeta's
family not only
not on planet but
something held true close by the young
Prince's heart he has stolen his will to
fight the Legendary Super Saiyan feels
like nothing more than a myth to him now
that like everything else in existence
it sits beneath the might of the
terrible and terrifying Lord frees us
[Applause]
Goku's arrival here may Echo the very
same scenario in the arc prior but its
tone could not be more different there
are no smiles and senzu beans only
uncertainty and abject Terror and as a
thematic through line begins to build
Toriyama incorporates toei's Bardock
special into its manga directly tying
Goku's Heritage into the annihilation of
Planet Vegeta itself it's a great
literary move and one that helps shift
the terror towards frieza's Direction
instead as he thinks back on that
character Goku Dodges his attack
effortlessly and it reignites Vegeta's
resolve if only for a moment
[Applause]
I love everything about this section so
very much this is genuinely Toriyama at
his absolute Peak this harrowing
sequence works so wonderfully on two
levels for Vegeta this is his Saiyan Arc
Piccolo moment his transition to a
legitimate Ally this tragic death speech
tells the tale of a man subjugated for
years it appeals to Goku's kind-hearted
nature and it solidifies in Goku the
need to accept an avenge his heritage
as Goku buries Vegeta there's this
wonderful moment of understanding
between the two rivals he asks for some
of Vegeta's Saiyan pride and as he turns
to face Frieza with the weight of Planet
Namek and Vegeta on his shoulders
he says
but before we head into this phenomenal
finale we must first take a step back
once again to look at the incredible
staff who brought this Ark to life
last week I spent some time introducing
the many studios that Encompass Dragon
Ball Z's production outlining the key
staff alongside their strengths and
weaknesses and as we now step forth into
the Frieza Arc things are beginning to
really ramp up with some of the most
amazing episodes of the series and the
promotion of some incredible staff with
the start of the Saiyan Arc a directed
by the name of tatsuya orime was
promoted from an assistant director to a
lead director role and although he would
still provide assistance on other
directors episodes within Z in spite of
this the ones he led solo would soon
begin to turn heads and become some of
the most notable around this was already
true in the aftermath of the cyanark
where its harrowing consequences were a
background element of the manga
whileorime brought them to the Forefront
in one truly devastating episode
foreign
[Music]
board some great fights but it's not
until Namek proper that he truly
showcases his skill episode 66 has one
of the strongest storyboards of the show
so far packed with some awesome looking
angles on some great creative lighting
decisions for the more abstract moments
What's neat here is that this is
actually a studio live episode who if
you remember from last week is led by
Yukio ibizawa and uh well his art
certainly isn't getting any better in
this Arc and he does still produce an
episode here that is genuinely one of
the worst looking episodes in the entire
291 episode run however there is an
awesome Silver Lining here back in
episode 46 studiolive gained a new staff
member toshiyuki Kano although tomiida's
worked improved greatly in this era it
was kano's town that almost
single-handedly elevated Studio lives
output packing their episodes full of
awesome drawings that definitely stand
out when they hard cut too ebiza was
questionable output
Studio live wasn't the only Studio to
see changes however the Undisputed goat
I'd say gosh has shifted things around
dramatically during this Arc while
takayuchi continued to supervise
episodes through the initial portion of
this material his two All-Star animators
shimanuki and hisada were quickly
becoming completely Unstoppable dropping
the most insane work episode after
episode and well takayutu's work
particularly his Corrections weren't
looking so hot anymore as a result
takayuti would step down from his
position falling back to a regular key
animator and in his place shimanuki and
hisada would begin to trade turns
leading episodes shimanuki first took
this position in episode 68 with a very
obvious leap in quality and with him
came the debut of a very famous name
these days now kitate prior to this Tate
had been an in-between artist at segasha
but with things shifting around it was
time his talents were made the best of
and so moving to key animator made a lot
of sense he saw the supervision began
much later in the arc with episode 98
and the Run of episodes here is
genuinely jaw dropping and arguably some
of the strongest animation output ever
found in the series every episode
sagasha delivers in this Arc just
contains the most absurdly strong work
packed full of things like shimanuki's
impactful punches and his side as crazy
Dynamic movement and what's more is
they're so often paired with Incredible
directors like yoshihiro ueda who just
douses scenes in his trademark pink
color work so everything just oozes with
Incredible atmosphere it really is just
the perfect storm of Dragon Ball Z's top
talent at this point and before we move
on let me just tell you all about the
segasha head turn these status guys have
one of these awesome turns in almost all
of their episodes and it's one of the
most defining aspects of their work you
will never be able to unsee it now that
I pointed it out by the way Mondo cool
speaking of defining though shindo
Productions sees an interesting shift in
their episodes I spoke last episode
about how mitsuo shindo himself is a
really strict supervisor and while that
definitely is still true one of his
underlings is very regularly standing
out in spite of that and that person is
tadayoshi yamamuro while his animation
work here might not necessarily blow
your minds to a modern lens as it looks
like typical Dragon Ball action this
type of frenetic heavily choreographed
animation was really the first of its
kind in the Z series gamamora was
redefining how Dragon Ball should move
and that influence will carry forward
across the entire show Shido himself
clearly recognized this talent and
allowed yamura to start assisting him
with corrections throughout this Arc and
that's a very important note to remember
given what's to come in the next episode
of this series but let's not get ahead
of ourselves Studio Junior likewise saw
a major Talent recognizing Talent moment
in this Arc too while Menorah maida is
still very much the lead in the series
this Arc saw him split between many
duties primarily the production of the
Dragon Ball Z films one man only has so
much time and so his two top underlings
masaki Sato and katsuyoshi nakitsuru
were handed animation supervisory roles
with the latter even going as far as to
lead the entire Paradox special with
supervision and design work sato's
episode comes early on and is a real
powerhouse I mean this is arguably one
of the best looking episodes in the
entire series of course sato's art is
amazing but the actual movement here is
so damn good too towards the start of
this Arc an in-house toy animator by the
name of gnocchi miyahara joined The Fray
and showcasing a very strong talent for
action and his work here is no exception
he's a name that will soon become more
and more prominent as time goes on so
definitely keep him in mind and
alongside him The Usual Suspects such as
takeoide and Hisashi iguchi are here to
carry even more on their backs joining
miyahara in ensuring this fight is one
to remember and if you think it's hard
to tell these scenes apart you wouldn't
be wrong Sato redrew almost all of the
art to ensure it was of the absolute
highest quality no matter what this
whole episode is honestly straight up
stunning maida does take back over
towards the latter part of the Ark and
while his work is okay we've definitely
hit a point where not only are his
Juniors completely surpassing the skills
but so are many of the other Studio's
talents and as a result you'll see that
iconic moments like the Super Saiyan
transformation come from masaki SATA
without any mayada input by the way if
you haven't seen that episode in a while
you might be shocked how jarring it is
Goku's all ragey Super Saiyan one minute
and then at higher cuts to Bulma and the
Frog
[Music]
kill him
also in pacing decision everyone well
done now on to the last Studio last
house
if you don't recall last houses led by
masayuki uchiyama who's kind of been a
punching bag for fans for a very long
time and we'll get there but his
episodes are still largely serviceable
in this Arc as I mentioned last episode
naitoshi shida and taichiro Ohara are
two key animators under him and boy do
they carry you so hard in this Arc she
just seriously comes into his own here
really pulling out the old super fast
Speedy weeny awesomeness we all know and
love it's all so full of energy and
really conveys the insane speed that had
us all glued to her Collective TV
screens as kids growing up on this show
Ohara is kinda similar except he's like
what if I drew the most insane looking
effects and put all my heart and soul
into animating Vegeta getting his ass
kicked and what's funny is that as
lackluster azuchiyama's art might feel
in comparison to the surrounding staff
except debizawa I do have to kind of
give him props for reigning in O'Hara
who genuinely draws characters like an
actual insane person caveman Goku
ugabuga heck he even improves a young
natoshi shida in some of the more
complex angles and okay at this point
you might be wondering what happened to
that solo animator you mentioned last
episode to answer your question
unfortunately Oshima ran away to work on
some far less demanding shows I mean who
can really blame him with how
action-packed this series suddenly got
but of course as you've no doubt
gathered so far the Frieza Arc of this
show saw huge developments across the
board to the point that losing a
supervisor like this simply really
didn't affect the production all that
much in fact the series gained a name in
the form of a director one that was soon
redefine Dragon Ball Z and go on to
influence a generation of animators but
that my friends is a story for another
time and right now we've got bigger
things to deal with
I Am Lord Frieza I am emperor of the
universe die in disgrace
[Music]
Goku vs Frieza in the previous video I
taught in the philosophies that informed
Goku and Vegeta's respective lives and
while I acknowledge on the servers that
their approaches might share a lot in
common with regards to these two the
devil doesn't just stand before them
it's also very much in the details where
someone like Vegeta could be mentally
overwhelmed by the likes of frieza's
power alone acting as confirmation that
he will never be what he wants to be
more than anything else the strongest
for Goku the mere presence of Frieza and
the power he boasts only serves to fuel
his enthusiasm in many respects as all
he wants to do is fight stronger
opponents and as is the case with Frieza
he's found his Golden Goose
[Music]
following the opening exchange between
Goku and Frieza King Kai says the
Saiyans are interesting people
particularly Goku I think there seems to
be no limit to his strength where the
themes of the Saiyan Saga focused on the
differences that existed between the
Heroes of Earth and the invading Saiyan
forces with a specific Focus placed on
the virtues of teamwork work ethic and
the bonds forged over one's life the
emphasis in this opening flurry explores
less the themes I pointed out just now
but more so what each fighter represents
in the greater context of the story in
spite of their clear ideological
differences Frieza is an immovable
object thought to be impossible to
topple and Goku an Unstoppable Force the
likes of which isn't seeming to let up
either anytime soon both seemingly
Limitless individuals squaring off to
push themselves like no one else has
before the fashion by which Akira
Toriyama explores this very difference
between the two with regards to power is
my favorite aspect of this story and it
all started here when Goku did this
to make it
[Music]
this is a clever piece of creative
strategy which leverages a clear area
that Goku is superior over Frieza in
much like Raditz Napa and Vegeta in the
prior Arc Frieza 2 is held back
considerably by his lack of ability to
sense the key of his opponents however
unlike Vegeta who never learned it for
egotistical reasons or lack of exposure
to a particular skill set Frieza never
needed to for he has never encountered
in all of his life anyone who even
remotely approaches a fraction of his
base power he said it himself earlier in
this opening exchange I'm a bit
surprised I didn't think anyone in the
universe surpassed Captain Ginyu someone
who we now know was 0.1 percent of the
power frees his final form boasts and so
therefore what I found fascinating about
this plan of attack wasn't simply the
reapplication of a successful approach
taken in Prior arcs that being Goku
using his key sensitivity to gain the
advantage in battle but instead the
subversion of a notion in that an
approach like that would do anything
against someone as a monstrous as Frieza
however a lot of this or perhaps all of
it goes unnoticed at first to us as
viewers and readers specifically because
we know that both parties are holding
back almost the point of just playing
around and while Goku may very well
anticipate that from Frieza the reverse
is very much not true Frieza has never
met someone like Goku someone who would
even consider the notion of being able
to quote hold back anything against the
mighty Lord Frieza Goku is very much a
man whom when you fight him you're
picking a fight with every last one of
his allies and Masters that have passed
what they have learned unto him all of
this achieves a sense of calm confidence
in Goku that comfortably grants him safe
passage across this warm-up and at this
point in the fight while things are
tense as an audience we know what Goku
has in reserve we think he might just
have this and then Frieza reveals an
unsettling truth
no I think what was once a playful but
competitive contest between what had
been up until that point two demigods
duking it out for Supremacy has revealed
to us a colossal discrepancy and
strength the likes of which looks
insurmountable to overcome for Goku
however we
come back from warsaws we've seen him
topple the likes of the mightiest and
mutarins it in this universe almost
single-handedly and we aren't about to
give up hope on the primary defender of
the earth and now Namek just yet
knows this
I mentioned during my coverage of the
San Arc that something Akira Toriyama
leveraged to drive home Goku's
realization of his grandpa Gohan's fate
was a literary technique called dramatic
irony in the case of Dragon Ball unlike
Goku we knew how his grandpa came to die
but Goku never knew this and that is
what dramatic irony is the audience
knowing something a character doesn't
such an approach empowers the reader to
create expectations and in the case of
the previous Arc it allowed us to
experience the somber revealed to Goku
of the truth that he was an unwitting
Beast that killed his own grandpa this
was of course a conscious decision made
by Akira Toriyama to enhance the impact
of the moment for us at home for us not
to be distracted by the revelation of
the information itself but to instead
focus our attention on the reaction from
Goku in the moment and the impact on him
that Revelation had but for this fight
with Frieza Akira Toriyama flips the
reader's knowledge and expect stations
against them weaponizing that very
foresight we have because we know how
many things Goku has up his sleeve we
know he hasn't even begun to use the
Kamehameha the Taio Ken the weighted
clothing he might be wearing and not to
mention the Kaioken which as he said
allows him to literally take his power
we have seen time and time again that
Goku is able to dip into these reserves
these tricks up his sleeve and utilize
him to overcome whatever stands in his
way whether it be against ten shinhan
Piccolo Vegeta or anyone else who has
ever had the upper hand against him we
know Goku has something up his sleeve
ready to turn the tides this fight
against Frieza is still in its opening
act and we haven't even begun to see
what this new and improved Goku can do
in other words Akira Toriyama has set
our expectations and that's when he
writes one of the greatest mic drops in
this series is history because
Goku is already out of Tricks
unbeknownst to us he has been using the
Kaioken this entire time there are no
more weighted clothes to take off no new
abilities to reveal he is already maxed
out and Frieza isn't even half triangle
[Music]
[Applause]
ever since I was a little kid sitting on
the couch this has remained my favorite
scene in the entire anime for decades
this is at a top above all else for me
and strangely it's a scene that contains
a considerable amount of creative
Liberty taken by those at toy animation
and not Akira Toriyama an aspect of the
story many who haven't read the Manga
find difficult to understand or even
reconcile
oh yeah
[Music]
this short but empowering Battle Cry
Goku Echoes to himself before risking it
all on a times 20 Kaioken that would
surely ravage his entire body is the
sort of never give up attitude in the
name of his loved ones that I've grown
to adore and take tremendous inspiration
from A vibe that persists in the
original Japanese broadcast also however
the manga and Akira Toriyama tell a very
different story in 1996 during an
interview with Wired Magazine when asked
about the poison that dwells within
Goku's character kiratoriyama had this
to say Son Goku from Dragon Ball doesn't
fight for the sake of others but because
he wants to fight against strong guys so
once Dragon Ball got animated at any
rate I've always been dissatisfied with
the righteous hero type portrayal they
gave him I guess I couldn't quite get
them to grasp the elements of poison
that slipped in and out of sight amongst
the Shadows I think it's important to
include here that I don't think Akira
Toriyama is suggest suggesting when he
says poison that Goku is pure evil or
never does anything selfless as moments
after this in the manga when charging
the Genki dama Goku goes on to say the
following if I don't stop Frieza now the
whole universe will be in danger and so
while those elements are in his mind I
think what Toriyama is trying to get
across here is that while Goku does
value his family and friends his desire
to fight strong opponents and better
himself is primary this element to his
character surfaced during the closing
chapters of the Saiyan Saga allowing
Vegeta to escape a choice that was
likely going to bring about more horror
and torment than what Goku would gain by
enjoying a fight with him later this is
to say that while I adore the scene as
it exists in the anime the difference
between the two is Stark in the anime it
is built up at length with Goku being
drowned followed by Goku rising up
tremendously with fire in his heart as
he risks his entire body and life on the
final times 20 Kamehameha a final Act of
desperation fueled by his determination
to not only overcome the obstacle but
protect those he loves but in the manga
it is just pure desperation there is no
inspiring speech no dramatic build up
just Goku praying to himself that Frieza
is bluffing and desperately staking it
all on one big attack and unfortunately
Frieza was in fact not bluffing while
the flurry did manage to hurt Frieza at
least all it did was manage to royally
tick Frieza off not that it really
matters even with Goku sacrificing it
all to Levy 20 times his base power it
didn't budge Frieza even at half his
strength he knows he's outclassed Beyond
a chance and so does Piccolo who with a
tortured smile on his face says exactly
what we're all thinking it's a total
loss like Kyle said we shouldn't have
Tangled with Frieza no matter what
laughs
much the same way Goku was driven to
desperation by the likes of Vegeta he
has once again begun to rely on the
strength of those around him channeling
what is at this point his most powerful
attack the Genki Dharma and with it
comes that very same tremendous amount
of tension totally Zapped of energy on
the verge of collapse his guard totally
down and the only line of defense
between him and Frieza being his Brazen
attitude poking the Tyrant and while
this is purely conjecture I like to
think that Frieza didn't pick up on the
enormous Genki Dharma right away because
he's so used to never needing to check
his blind spots while the likes of
Krillin Gohan and Piccolo locate the
giant sphere of energy almost
immediately on the other hand Frieza
only manages to notice it when he's
taunting and mocking Goku noticing it
through the reflection of the water
behind him it's a terrifying moment and
being totally drained it's a discovery
that all but seals Goku's fate
[Applause]
I love this story so damn much I might
get an aneurysm before I finish this
video just like the arc prior when his
back is up against the wall and has no
other options available to him his
allies all pulled their energy together
and the one to risk his life isn't his
son Gohan or his best friend Krillin
this time it's his one-time enemy
Piccolo where the Genki dammit in the
prime material possessed a thematic
resonance with it being a physical
manifestation of Goku's allies all
working together to defy Vegeta in this
it has an additional dimension of the
surrounding planets lending their energy
for the conflict with this one technique
Goku acts as the vessel offering a
chance for all living things he can
reach to defend themselves against this
Tyrant of the universe Frieza to prevent
Namek and our heroes from suffering that
same fate
all right
there's an aspect to this attack that
I've never touched on before and it's in
the way Frieza is hit by it and the way
that he reacts to it firstly he's caught
off guard as Goku said in the opening to
this fight Frieza is overconfident which
leaves him open to attack and it did not
once not twice but a third and Powerful
time in this sequence also and in the
manga the sort of character he is shines
through perfectly in his reaction to the
Genki dhamma itself in three stages at
first he exclaims this is nothing he
says this almost reflexively this is the
response he's used to giving towards
everything a Battle Cry that exists to
strike fear into the hearts of those who
dare defy him who laughably think any
attack they could ever Levy against the
emperor of the universe would do
anything however once contact is made he
reiterates this to himself this is
nothing almost as if to reassure to
himself
and one last time he tries to say it
again before a very clear fear Falls
across his face for the very first time
in this entire series for the very first
time perhaps in his entire life Frieza
feels the cold and lonely Embrace of
death at Faith befitting someone as
cruel as he and wouldn't bestowed upon
him by the longtime great ever tenacious
and never alone Son Goku once again
despite the road to get there despite
the obstacles or the challenges he faced
Goku has always managed to defy the odds
with a smile and with the help of his
friend
really
nice
[Music]
what happens when every Advantage you
thought you had fails you
what's left when clever strategy doesn't
work
when the martial arts you've honed for
your entire life isn't enough
when the techniques you've been able to
rely on fail over and over
and over again
what happens when your friends who've
been there with you since day one
not only can I help you
cannot save you
but they can't even save themselves
what's left at that point
[Music]
in the Saiyan Saga I spoke at length
concerning the differences in virtues of
Goku and the people of Earth how
believing in your fellow man and relying
on what your allies have offered you on
top of all of your hard work how all of
that can when faced with certain Doom
become your salvation
there's a powerful message in the core
of that Arc that I have carried with me
to this very day and as I said in this
video already this Arc stretches those
ideas and themes past their natural
limits until
Daybreak
[Music]
[Applause]
ER
this Goku feels different and what's
more is this fight suddenly feels
entirely different too the way Goku
barked at Gohan almost as if he were
holding himself back like he was
balancing on a Razor's Edge it created
for me an atmosphere that felt totally
distinct surrounding Goku than that
which I'd ever seen before and to drive
this fact home there's a moment that
hearkens back to the Saiyan Saga
involving Gohan during The Last Arc
after being sent Away by Goku before his
fight against Vegeta Gohan turns back at
the first sign of irregularity and his
instincts were correct
this time something similar takes place
a flicker of explosive energy blasts
ignite the sky behind him trouble is
taking place but the difference here
isn't that Gohan isn't being brave but
that he instead is certain his father
will be okay there's no doubt a
certainty and confidence in his father
that will continue to permeate not only
through to the end of this Arc but long
into the next and beyond for better
or For Worse at the at this present
moment Goku has done
pushed past his limits into that of
Legend and myth a once trembling body
riddled with fatigue and uncertainty has
been replaced with ice-cold confidence
and seemingly Limitless potential eyes
once fluttering on the verge of losing
Consciousness have transformed into
Spears piercing the very heart of the
usurper standing before him and the
voice which once muttered that he
couldn't win now erupts with a
triumphant roaring
a massive component of what makes Super
Saiyan both special to me as well as so
deeply impactful to the story and those
who read it is the contrast it
establishes between itself and other
abilities or Transformations that came
before visually it was striking in its
Simplicity but thematically it was born
amid circumstances unlike anything the
likes of which we've seen in the past
abilities and techniques Goku could rely
on back then born from his rearing or
the teachings of wise Masters were in
their first use almost a celebration of
something Goku went through in order to
wield the explosive power of the Kaioken
the Life Goku had led allowed him to
travel to Otherworld in his own body
thanks to his tenacity and physical
prowess he was able to Traverse snake
way and thanks to his openness and
eagerness to learn he was able to bond
with King Kai a friendship that proved
to be invaluable later and indeed one
that helped him learn the Kaioken a move
that exists because a positive
attributes Goku possesses and the
willingness of others to help him Super
Saiyan isn't that
foreign
apart from everything else at this point
in the story is that it's a power
exposed through profound sadness as if
it were the pain of loss and retribution
personified where each and every ability
Our Heroes Have utilized up until now
are born from their Undying Will to
improve themselves and the pursuit of
Greater strengths as a result
Super Saiyan stands alone against all of
them not a transformation born from
effort but a result of immense pressure
reaching a Tipping Point like a worn Dam
bursting or an abused animal trapped in
a corner it is the direct result and
retribution of what evil has been
wrought against Goku and the peaceful
Planet Namek at rebirth amid intense
trauma like channeling the power of the
sun if only for a moment an instant
change that allowed the user to walk a
dangerous line and wield a necessary
strength to Vanquish a terrible evil and
no matter who you are whether you're an
adult from the east or a little kid from
the West like I was there's something
unbelievably cathartic about that a
feeling that establishes one of the most
iconic and easily recognizable moments
in all of Japanese pop culture
[Music]
foreign
this is an important moment in the story
for sure but I never realized how
perfectly it establishes that the Super
Saiyan that stands before Frieza is
still Goku at the end of the day in the
same way Raditz never anticipated Goku
to hold him for the makan kosa PO or the
same way Napa never thought he'd have to
keep his guard up against someone like
chaotsu in that way when Frieza was
charging his blast Goku didn't realize
until the last second that that blast
intended target wasn't him in the end
it's a strategic play that's equal parts
ingenious as it is horrifically
Despicable for the first time since
donning this new form Goku's stoic
expression cracks as the Planet Namek
beneath him does the same consumed by
the blast it seems Frieza was destined
to win this war consumed by fear he too
was backed into a corner and forced to
pull a trigger he always had every
intention of using as a contingency
[Music]
foreign
the revelation of Kami in this scene is
a wonderfully fun way of proving that
all is not as it seems on Planet Namek
that Frieza miscalculated and that Goku
still has a chance to take out Frieza
and what's more the playing King Kai
comes up with concerning the remaining
Dragon Balls using the Earth's wish to
bring back the namekians and by doing so
bringing back Guru which in turn brings
back the dragon which still has a single
wish to Grant Dynamic everything is
working out and that's when the winds
change once again for just like Akira
Toriyama warned us there's always that
element of poison that slips in and out
amongst the shadows of Goku's character
a poison that rears its head once Frieza
reveals that he's not even fighting at
what hundred percent yet a fate that
could
be avoided Goku
Goku totally take Frieza out right here
and now this second with a well-placed
and Powerful Kamehameha a technique that
has saved him and his friends on more
than one occasion he could rely on his
friends then to make the wish for him on
the namekian Dragon Balls travel back
home with all of his loved ones safely
abandoning Frieza on the floating bomb
of his own Creation in the middle of
space but that poison that urge to
satisfy that burning question to test
himself to see what Frieza is hiding to
avenge his friend that burning dark
desire in Goku is more alluring than any
other option to him
and he doesn't regret it
towards the beginning of this video I
took note of an event on Namek referred
to as the cataclysm a climate-induced
event that ravaged their Planet almost
wiping out their entire namekian race
much like the dragon balls on Earth
which were limited by the power of their
own Creator the namekian Dragon Balls
couldn't prevent the disaster that was
to take place on theirs and looking at
it now perhaps this was intentional
perhaps it wasn't but in reading through
this material right now as the awakened
Warrior of Saiyan Legend clashes with
the tyrannical personification of evil
in the universe I can't help but see
some parallels to namek's tortured past
here that this event which has scarred
Namek irreparably that has resulted in
the near Erasure of an entire race of
people
similarly to the events of the past
which took Namek to the very Brink this
was a battle that was always destined to
take place and couldn't be avoided
warned against fighting Frieza Goku gets
excited as he draws closer to this
creature his desire to contend with him
only grows until he sheds any and all
worldly pretense and Embraces this clash
with Frieza as the planet destroying
event It ultimately becomes objecting to
The Wish King Kai wanted to have granted
not wanting to be wished back to Earth
thus leaving the fight early but instead
ensuring that he sees it through to The
Bitter End no matter what from the
moment we meet Frieza he strikes fear
into the hearts of all who oppose him he
slithers through this Ark with a
singular focus and expects everyone to
bow in subjugation in awe of his
abilities Goku similarly once he arrives
is presented as this Unstoppable demigod
the likes of which the guineus Vegeta
and even his own friends and family can
hardly believe both of these characters
similarly to the cataclysm itself which
Once Upon a Time destroyed Namek and his
people represent a similarly Unstoppable
force of nature neither Goku in his
determination to fight the absolute best
or to allow Frieza reach 100 in the
first place nor Frieza driven to Madness
in an effort to re-establish his own
dominance at being willing to take
whatever measure he needs to in order to
eviscerate the scum that dare defy him
neither are going to stop until one side
wins until one side is satisfied
until one side
quits
this scene is special to me within this
bright and magical almost dreamlike
story that helps us forget the torments
of the world and all of its ailments
it's indeed these dark and intensely
conflicted chapters that are the portion
of the story I return to most often and
I think it's because it reminds me of
something important
something I wish wasn't true
I've made it clear over the years that
Goku is one of my favorite characters of
all time and my absolute favorite in
this story by a considerable margin
while I have tremendous time for the
likes of Piccolo Gohan Vegeta and many
others as this Series has demonstrated
there's something important about Goku's
character to me that has remained a
consistent part of me since I was a
child and that is his ability to expect
the best from everyone and everything if
he can help it I've spoken about how I
adored his conviction against rats
willing to sacrifice himself in the name
of the greater good but prior to that
there's a moment where he had his
brother begging for his life he was in a
position where he could rest assured
that at the very least he Goku would be
safe but he released it anyway
I'm not under any illusion that Goku is
some deep thinker when it comes to
morality here but there's something so
infectious about how simple his actions
are and how at times those simple
actions can be profound exposing how we
all over complicate our lives sometimes
I've spoken about how when he was faced
with absurd challenges he's never shied
away from them but instead looked on
with almost witless optimism an attitude
that Echoes the philosophy of he who
thinks he can and he who thinks he can't
are both usually correct a philosophy
I've tried to apply to my own life tough
as it can be to do so at times and
throughout even this material Goku has
demonstrated time and again he doesn't
believe in killing people for the
Strategic sake of it that despite his
deep yearning to fight
he knows where to draw the line he after
having grown up with wonderful people
understands the value of life
but Frieza doesn't
foreign
where as I get older I feel increasingly
more jaded to the atrocities of men and
the hopelessness of it all I try on
occasion sappy as it may be to return to
these stories from my childhood because
there's a gentle Comfort to them when
we're children the world is full of
possibilities we can become anything and
we naive as it might seem think we can
bend the world in the right direction
but despite the evils it may contain or
the corruption that lurks in the shadows
the stories we've grown up with have
instilled within us this idea that if we
try hard enough we can break past that
which has limited every generation
before and perhaps part of that is true
perhaps believing we can and approaching
something with optimism is the way
forward in this Arc Goku has broken each
and every one of his limits over and
over again almost losing himself
entirely to the anger and lust for
combat that's appeared in his character
since the beginning of the story but
something did surprise me here
in the beginning of the Last Arc Goku
after hearing his brother's plea
released his tail because he believed
him he believed that his brother was
being honest that he could change
however when Goku spared Vegeta's life
and showed him Mercy he did so for
clearly selfish reasons and on Goku's
Adventure traveling to the battle
against the almighty Frieza he
encountered numerous reasons to turn
back but never did for again his own
self-interest however despite becoming
the Super Saiyan and despite this trend
of self-interest this show of Mercy to
Frieza in this scene never appeared as
anything other than genuine to me like
the Goku that fought and showed Mercy to
Raditz was still in there somewhere
after frieza's pathetic plea for help
Goku's eruption of anger all but
confirmed he wanted nothing more than to
be able to fly away and leave him to die
in the dirt thinking about what took
place before his inevitable death but he
didn't when were children we carry these
naive dreams with us until one day you
wake up and you're an adult and the
black and white world you thought you
knew is in fact revealed to be coated in
terrifyingly subtle Shades of Gray and
for me this scene despite contending
with one of the most evil characters put
to paper reminded me that sometimes the
righteous path the path of respect and
avoidance of death
sometimes no matter how much you might
wish it wasn't so
is unavoidable that even for the likes
of Goku someone who's overcome
everything prior who through his
conviction at heart has carved out a
place for himself in history as a god of
sorts through the likes of him I'm
reminded that no matter how far you
think you've come no matter how strong
you think you are how much you've
learned or the distance you've traveled
you can still stay true to who you are
but that doesn't mean it'll work
because sometimes there are those that
words alone cannot reach who in that
moment refuse to see the value in life
that you see
who no matter how unreasonably kind
you've been there are those who are so
far gone into their own delusions of
Supremacy fear and greed
that they can't change
[Music]
when I was a kid I used to think that
this scene was awesome I used to think
that Goku didn't compromise who he was
deep down to satisfy a base desire and I
relished in the likes of Frieza like
many other great villains I watch at the
time be the one to place the proverbial
noose around his own neck Frieza the
emperor of the universe who always
referred to Saiyans as unsophisticated
primitive brutish Apes in the end was
the one who acted like a Mindless beast
when all the chips were down and while
all of that is worthy of Praise as a
feat of tremendous dramatic writing in
and of itself as a young adult back in
the day this scene acted as my first
sobering reminder that sometimes while
indulging in a selfish desire can leave
you trapped
more than that kindness too can be
hopeless
in conclusion this video was even more
difficult to write than my last it
appears my feelings concerning this
series only gets more complicated as
time moves on but I hope that didn't
diminish your enjoyment of this
breakdown sincerely the Frieza Saga for
both personal reasons as well as its own
completely Standalone merits holds a lot
of emotional weight for me it's the
culmination of all that was established
in the arc prior and pays it off in some
of the most astounding ways I've ever
seen it's a work of art and while I've
completed this video I know I'll look
back on this piece I've written with
frustration for not expanding on another
aspect of this tale that mattered to me
greatly
but I suppose that's what great art does
allow you to see different things in it
over time and unfortunately because I've
thrown myself so deeply into this
material the cell Saga is going to take
a little longer to cover than I thought
and because I want to do it right I'm
going to have to delay it for one week
meaning you can anticipate that video on
August 12th but if you don't want to
wait that long you can always sign up to
our patreon where it will be posted as
soon as it's finished as well as some
sneak previews and all sorts of other
related perks either way I hope to see
you there for while the earthlings have
managed to wish their friends back
thanks to the courageous actions of sun
Gohan Krillin and the complicated Son
Goku along an eye-opening path still
lies before them one wrought with
death-defined battles and a
coming-of-age that capture the hearts
and minds of millions across the world
but as always I've been Mark Fitzpatrick
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you there
foreign